hello and welcome to this video now
before I do anything else let's get the
number incorrect
okay I'm playing the chess Indian and
he's playing what is he exactly playing
we don't know yet yeah he still has five
or g6 yep when he comes for pills I know
that I played them before absolutely
certain but you're not sure what I
opening that was I we can actually look
at this that looks funny
huh I wonder game okay
yeah 101 is on time I okay sorry um
castles
hmm what can I do here I can just play
Knight f3 on that's nothing wrong about
that Queen f3 is often a good
alternative I tend to forget what I
recommended by repertoire
it's just oftentimes go both moves are
good and you yeah I mean it if you have
two good moves it's fine yeah it's a bit
better to have have none and yeah just
play one of the one of the decent decent
choices yeah I always think that white
should be a bit more comfortable in such
a position you have more space and it's
not quite clear what Black's players
probably some f6 to break down the
center M yeah we'll take no really not
no other serious option
okay so just castling I guess oh yeah
yeah night Seaforths is that a move that
is worrisome then not so much but you
still wonder if you go b3 what exactly
this night will ever do so let's play it
I wonder if Bishop age 6 and trading is
the right choice here hmm he provide
maybe he wants to play Bishop to f5
yeah it's not the end of the world who
sent sent tonight back at least to see a
okay so so [ __ ]
it wants to go to eight I can do this by
the way just being a pest about this a
seven is a point I would take
yeah it was a bit awkward and now what
next
so cannot move much there it's
centralized
I'm just not I'm not doing anything
spectacular just slowly improve my
pieces I lost track a little bit about
this idea somehow
mmm I'm not I'm not so happy about this
the straight definitely helps him
okay
maybe if it's tempted to take I would be
quite happy to to see this but I did not
take him okay so let's just play this
play this ending attending Luke 7 maybe
you have any children
I need to speed up that's what I need to
do
I absolutely did not see that I was down
to 20 seconds that was was good that
there was the sound that woke me up a
little bit and ending has nothing
special at all form and then I what what
to do here the night should be recruit
just want to be annoying g5 Knight f5 as
a temple on the bishop
and the night might have a good post on
em for later on III for that matter the
night III King is 6 maybe here first and
then I have form and now I can take it
right
yeah sorry for cutting down on the
country at the time the time is not
helping yeah and and he resigned to this
ending him okay let's let's have a look
at this the ending man wasn't wasn't all
that much okay so we got this this year
yeah D takes was an option I was
thinking about it because then I got a
gifted d4 square him which is nice and
he still suffers a little bit with the
bishop once he aid and so on it's it's
also quite okay him this was some
actually quite fine for black I think
and I would have expected him to take
with the PSM not that the pawn I was
thinking taking with the bishop which is
not mentioned at all okay because this
used to be a problem okay okay and
people more interested in this part of
the game to see what was going on if
okay so a five would have been
interesting but this this must be a
little something
okay you money Bishop f5 and here to
take and what should d2
I don't yet understand what is wrong
with this queen-to-be form
yeah that's very computer a shaman once
you see it you kind of get the idea
a5 the knight moves i take on b7 well
that's not the kind of thing a human
easily considers in particular in blitz
yeah okay look f2 queen d5 tempting him
to take didn't do that me not that this
is like lost or anything but I still
would have liked this yeah now with the
time ticking down I was going for yeah
keep it simple to just try to play a
simple endgame yeah h6 that was helpful
I think go back up here see Froy have
taught about this but I wanted to wanted
the regrouping and yeah after we should
be 894 things I'm really already quite
quite fatal I think I hope that I didn't
screw anything up I should have taken
only seven-year maybe just take this
opportunity but it's not a big issue
the bishop does not have any good square
anyway yeah and yeah no way no way to
save to save this game for black so
around here things weren't so terrible
for for him but the defense is not all
that easier f5 take g5 wow this again
once once you see it you you see the
point but finding it in a game is
different metal yeah this is already
quite quite annoying but this is not not
helping f5 is supposed to be better so
I'll take a--take and then see for now
I'm not sure that I would have played C
form allowing him to get rid of that
weakness maybe it's the only way forward
but still then when you get a passed
pawn it it's quite obvious that white
must be a bit better here but I'm not
sure that I've played c4 okay guys
thanks for watching